dropping out of college because you
disagree with their views is actually
just an excuse to hide the fact that you
could handle it this one's a personal
attack
personal attack you need to wait a
second okay so well no that gives me a
pretty good a pretty good answer for you
but then you got to answer for me
yeah i'm gonna say no yeah i think i
think any real conservative person would
say that you're giving hundreds of
thousands of dollars to an institution
that hates your values
yeah because it's not even it's not even
just like
you're leaving because we have different
preferences or something what i'm saying
i actually love liberal education i'm a
big supporter of not even forget stem
i'm talking about reading
poetry and history and stuff but
if you're not getting that if you're not
getting a real liberal education at a
college and you're spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars to do it
get out of there man what are you doing
maybe either transfer to another school
or just
like read books you know and go get a
job i mean that's what i did i mean i
went through two years of school and i
learned almost nothing the only classes
i failed all my classes except for
creative writing creative writing were
the only classes my english classes
because that was something that i
actually enjoyed and wanted to do yeah
but the other classes i mean the
sociology 101 and then the biology even
getting into gender stuff it doesn't
make any sense the biology class where
you learn that a man is a woman yeah the
men menstruate yeah there were live
performances on stage showing us exactly
how that is
that's the time to check out yeah
you